Welcome to "Ear Biscuits," the podcast,
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
I'm going to get your update
on sending your oldest child
off to college.
Yep.
I'm so proud of you
Rhett, you're following
in my footsteps, you're being a parent
who succeeds.
You got a living, thriving-
Thank you for showing
me the way.
Child out of your house
by following my simple program.
What? It was the program?
My simple one step program.
Let your child pick a
college and then pay for it
and take them there.
Is that the program?
I thought you could tell me.
Yeah, I guess that's it.
Actually I do have something,
but I'm not going to share-
I really built that up as
if I would have a joke,
but I didn't have one.
Yeah, I was like, where's this joke going?
That was walking out on
the plank and then just
jumping into the sea.
I had a couple of options in my mind,
but they were all so
self-deprecating that they
might have seemed real.
Oh, well you should do that more
None of these are actual
jokes, it seems like I'm
a bad father.
I have a non joke
thing that I will share later about having
talked about you sending
Lily off a year ago,
actually did impact an
aspect, that contributed to,
not the process of sending them off,
but the past year, which I'll talk about.
Oh, I thought it was in
the process cause I have
one very specific question;
if you did, this is something
that I did, but I'm going to
wait and see if you share it.
Take a walk and ugly cry at night;
is that the specific question?
Nope. That's not it.
It's different than that.
Did I see a woman that was in a bush?
What was it that you saw?
Peeing?
No.
But I did have something
very exciting happen to me
last night that I have to share
just because it's so timely.
Okay.
I was bitten by a spider.
Oh really?
A lot of times you don't know
when that happens until later.
Whoa, buddy!
Like, what's this on my arm
and the a doctor's like,
"You got bit by a spider."
And apparently the ones that, well,
I don't want to spoil it.
So Shepherd and I were in the pool,
which this is weird, this is very strange,
and the lights in the pool were off.
Well, it's your pool.
The fact that we were in our
pool is not the strange part.
Okay.
The lights were off in the pool,
and all of a sudden I felt a
pain in my right titty.
Oh, wow! Right there on your peck?
Right at the part of me that
was exposed to the surface.
Above your swimming tank top?
Yeah, right above that.
And I was like, "Oh crap!"
Immediately reached down, hit something,
actually grabbed something
and felt something
large in my hand and I was
like, "Oh, crap, what is it?!"
And then I threw it down and I was like,
"Shepherd, turn the lights on the pool!"
I was panicking.
I'm glad I was not being filmed.
Oh my god.
And then all of a sudden we look,
he turns the lights on
and it's a spider, and
this spider is swimming
in the pool.
Which that, first of all, is unusual.
Are we talking backstroke
or was it flailing
or did it seem like-
It wasn't supposed to be in the pool.
It wasn't like, oh,
I'm here and I'm happy.
You might have brought him in.
But it was-
Off you unkept beard.
It was big enough
to be,
you throw a little spider into
the water and it just kind of
immediately dies, and I was
like, this thing is surviving.
It bit me and now it's swimming?
What is going on?
Was it black?
Well, it was very hard to tell
because the lights were on
in the pool and it was
nighttime, so I couldn't tell.
And so Shepherd, immediately is like,
"Dad, you need to go
to the emergency room."
I'm like,
"Shepherd,
I appreciate your concern,
but we live in the age of the internet
and we are going to determine,"
I mean, this is the beautiful
thing about being alive today.
Could probably take a picture
of the spider and then
it would tell you what type it is.
Yeah, you go to Spider.net
and you just take it, put it in there.
Well, I think step one would've been to
net out the spider in
case you needed to keep it
for reference.
Well, that's what Shepherd said we needed;
take the spider and you
to the emergency room.
Good. Someone's the father
And I was like,
And it's not you.
"Well, hold on, that might be the case."
Then it died.
As we began to talk about
it and direct our attention
toward it, he was like, "I'm outy."
See, that's a bad sign.
He died.
That means it gave you so much of itself,
it gave you everything it had.
I think it was just, I wasn't
supposed to be in the pool,
I'm going to take a little
revenge cause I know this is not
going to end well and
then now I'm going to die.
And at that point night-
This is last night?
Last night. I'm shining-
You're getting a little pale.
I'm shining my light as the
spider floats in the pool,
and we're looking at it and
trying to figure out what it is
and Shepherd's like, "Dad,
that's a brown recluse."
Or he was like, it's a brown
widow, which I think he meant
to say brown recluse,
which is the most poisonous
spider that you can have in California.
He's like, "Dad, how do you feel?"
He's like, "We need to go to
the emergency room right now."
Yeah, cause it bit you on
the, I mean it didn't bit you-
Next to the heart.
Over the heart,
it bit over the what, liver?
The lung?
You think the liver's up? The
liver's down here, brother.
Oh the liver's tall, man.
It goes a Locke higher than you think.
Yeah, but it's more down here.
It's behind the lung I
think on your right side
a little bit.
And so, I wasn't panicking
because I was like,
I don't think,
a brown recluse and a black
widow and all the spiders
that are poisonous in
California, they're so shy,
they're not swimming, they're
not doing the breaststroke
in your pool and seeking
you out to bite you.
This is going to be one
of those spiders that it's
not even a web spider,
like a hairy spider,
like a wolf spider maybe,
something like that,
and they're not a problem.
So I'm not really panicking,
but Shepherd is really trying
to get me to panic.
Are you looking at the bite spot?
He's like, "Is it swelling?"
I'm like, "Dude, I don't even
know where," it hurt
pretty bad as it happened,
but I can't find a spot or
anything, but he's like,
"Dad, it doesn't matter
if you can't find a spot
because the worst ones,
you don't even feel them
and then they get big and then,"
I'm like, everything's going to be okay.
You got to cut it out,
you've got to cut out all the
wounded flesh.
Yeah.
Now here's the thing;
it's just me and Shepherd at home because
Locke's obviously at college,
Jessie's still there with him,
she flies back today.
So I think he was also thinking that
I'm a 13 year old, the only adult is here
and he might be about to
die from a spider bite,
I've got to start moving and shaking,
putting together plans.
But I'm gaining confidence
that this is first of all,
I know it wasn't a black
widow and I was like,
it doesn't look like a brown
recluse from what I remember.
Again, Shepherd was like,
"Let's get the net and take him
and put him on the thing."
So we did that.
And then I'm like, spiders
in Southern California
and then Google automatically
gives you 20 entries, right?
And then we start looking
through them and I'm like,
okay, it's not a brown recluse,
it's not any of the things
I should be scared of, I think.
And meanwhile, Shepherd's like,
"Dad, are you feeling okay?"
I'm like, "Yes, son, I'm feeling great!"
I'm going to shoot a
web right in your face.
And then I get to a wolf,
and I know I say that wrong,
wolf, wolf.
Wolf.
Wolf?
Wolf spider.
And I'm like, that's what it is.
And that makes sense that
they're bigger, hairier and
more stout spiders, thicker
legs, it makes sense that they
could swim around in the pool for a while.
And it was like, "You have
nothing to be frightened of."
So some people might be
allergic to the venom
of a wolf spider, but apparently I'm not.
I can't even see where it bit me.
It hurt pretty bad.
It was known to have a
painful bite, I was like,
"Yes, sir, it does."
Like a bee sting?
Bee stings hurt and then
immediately hurt more.
This hurt and didn't hurt again at all.
Huh.
There is venom, but I just
don't think he did much to me.
Okay.
So you you're able to give
Shepherd peace of mind
so he could sleep last night.
He was still looking at me as
I was walking up the stairs
and make sure I didn't collapse.
Do you want to put a
baby monitor in there?
But I was so grateful
because what would I have done
in 1982?
You'd have just waited it out
and nothing would've happened.
Well,
I think people knew more back then
because they didn't have the internet.
They didn't have this knowledge base
that they could just consult.
So I think there was some dad
somewhere in the neighborhood,
he was like-
You don't have to know
things cause you can know it
immediately when you need it.
What would happen is
you would know somebody
like Mike MacHarg, right?
Yeah.
And you would call him on the landline,
hopefully he would answer,
hopefully his
kids wouldn't be on the phone
talking to their boyfriends
or something and you'd get a busy signal.
I'm just trying to do it 82 here.
He answers and I'm like, "Mike,
I just got bit by spider,"
and I can't send you a picture
because that's not how it works,
"I'm going to describe it to you.
It's light brown, but it has
stripes like a watermelon
on its big fat part."
Oh, it had a big fat part?
It got me with that, I don't
know, what part does a,
they bite you with their fangs, right?
They don't sting.
Yeah, yeah,
they're not a, yeah, I believe so.
And he would say, "Oh it's
probably a wolf spider
or it could be a
gray house garden spider or something."
He'd have something, and you'd be like,
"You got nothing to worry
about, unless you're allergic
to the venom."
You got to just have a friend;
in 82, you had to have a
friend that was the internet.
Or the library.
Now you just don't even
have to have friends.
That's the beautiful thing about 2022.
There also weren't urgent cares.
You had to actually go to an ER.
Yeah, it wasn't that middle ground of
I don't want to call this an emergency.
Sometimes calling it an
emergency makes it an emergency.
I'm just going to say I need urgent care.
It took it took way too
long to figure that out.
So, I mean thanks for asking; I'm fine.
You look a little peaky.
You know what the thing is?
I got bit by spider. I don't
think it's ever happened.
Oh, it's happened.
I mean, I know I've eaten
like eight spiders a year
or whatever.
According to that, but I don't
think I've ever been bitten
by spider and so-
And known it.
You know what?
Scratch that off the list.
But that's not what we're talking about.
Poor guy sacrificed himself.
Oh.
Jenna says spider sting.
Technically called a sting.
It's called a sting?
Yeah.
Because it's not-
It's not the clamping
of the teeth that hurts?
Yeah, yeah.
It's the injection of the venom?
Yeah, it's considered
similar to a wasp sting
as well.
But there's no stinger.
It's with the mouth.
It is established, so
technically called a sting.
Yeah. It's a sting from the mouth.
Well, I think we might need
to contact the biologist
about this, let's call it a bite.
I think we should.
I guess a bite.
If you're using your
mouth, it's a bite, bro.
I guess a bite has to be
the top and bottom mendable.
Oh, that's it.
If I took my top teeth and
dropped them into your-
A vampire doesn't-
Shoulder, it would be
stinging you.
Doesn't necessarily bite.
A vampire might sting.
A vampire stings.
Cause they're just using the fangs.
Unless they use their bottom teeth too.
What about a snake?
A snake's just using the top fangs.
They're stinging too.
Yeah. What's going on here?
Yeah.
Come on.
We need the internet.
So where does this journey begin?
Well, I feel like I need to
make a note about, okay, so,
this required flying.
This is the first time I've
been in close proximity
to anyone who went to
college that they couldn't
drive to college.
We drove to college.
I drove Lily to college.
I brother drove to college.
Your kid was driven to college.
My nieces and nephews,
they're in the same
state or one state over.
And so I was like,
this is interesting, we
have to take everything
that he needs on a plane or
buy it and have it shipped there.
Yeah, cause for me with Lily,
it was all five of us in a car,
but then
we had a carrier on top
and then we had everything jam packed in.
It was one of those
things where it's like,
all right, you need to get
in your seat so that then
I can put another piece of luggage.
Oh, you just wait.
That's going to have to be unpacked before
you can get out.
I can't imagine,
there's no way to take
that amount of stuff
if you're flying.
Well, we didn't.
We had stuff shipped
there and we also arrived-
You packed some boxes that you shipped?
No, no, no, no.
Jessie, which we will
get into this detail,
but she was most
invested and
she was the one that was
working with Locke to make
the decisions about
the design of his dorm.
Design?
Oh yeah.
She interior designed his,
almost called it hotel room,
which is kind of what it feels like,
but it's smaller than that.
Well, how many roommates?
Just one roommate.
I'm getting ahead of myself
because I wanted to talk about,
the school is in the state of Florida.
That's why we had to
fly and not drive.
Your favorite state.
And let me just make a couple observations
about the people of Florida.
Now I know that we talk quite a bit-
That's never been done before.
I know that we talk quite a bit about
Mythical Beasts
recognizing us in the wild.
I'm sorry if you're tired
of it, but I'm going to
do it again because every time we go out,
there's a different aspect
that I'm introduced to
now that we're kind of traveling again.
And this, there's two things
about the people of Florida,
specifically, and I'm
maybe going to call them
Mythical Beasts because
that's one of the points,
is that
I've never been so consistently
recognized by people
who actually don't know who I am.
They don't say, "Big fan."
"Hey, Rhett."
It might be, "Good mythical morning,"
if they can remember the
name of the show, but mostly
it's like, "Oh, what is the thing?
You guys, you taste the stuff."
Yeah.
So it's what I would call
the casual fan.
It's the people clicking
on the food videos.
It's the reason that the
food videos get the views
is because the casual fan is
like, "Oh, those two idiots
are tasting something again,
I'm going to click on it.
I don't really know, I can't
really remember who they are,
but they're on YouTube."
I like other things
on YouTube a lot more than you.
Yeah! Very much the case.
These are a couple of quotes that
were said to me.
One was; "Are you still friends
with the guy with glasses?"
That was one of the first things.
Oh wow.
Are you still friends
with the guy with glasses?
That could be a very
dedicated Mythical Beast,
cause if you get way too dedicated,
then that's the question
you started asking.
Why are they mad at each other?
Well, and I responded with,
and Jessie pointed out
later, but this sounded
a little cold,
I was like, "Yeah, we're
still working together."
Still working together.
And what I meant was,
yeah, we're still making our
show that you know us from.
And Jessie was like-
That hurt, man.
You made it sound like
you weren't friends.
I was like, well they
don't even know who I am.
They're not going to go be able to find us
to spread a rumor anyway.
Well, we're still working together.
The other one was, "Where's your buddy?"
It wasn't "Where's
Link?" which I get a lot.
"Where's your buddy?"
Where's your buddy?
And I was like, "I don't know."
I don't know right now.
Not here.
Yeah.
You did not enlist my
services to help you move.
I guess I would've done it,
but thank you for not asking.
One thing this has made me think of-
Can you fly with me so
that you can take an extra
carry on bag for my son?
That's how I would've been
approached with the move.
Thankfully we didn't need that.
One of the things that I
am thinking about though
is I would like to,
I need your location shared with me
cause I get asked so often where you're at
and I just want to be able to
pull up a phone and be like,
"Well, there he is right there."
So many people ask where
you're at when they see me
that I would like to know
exactly your coordinates
and then I will screenshot it
and send it to these people.
Okay. Okay.
So they'll know.
Because they are very curious.
You want me to share my location
with you so that you can-
I can share it with randoms.
Willy-nilly with strangers.
Yes.
Okay.
You know what?
You good?
Let's actually pause the
recording so I can do that now.
I don't want to delay a second.
Here's the second Florida
thing that, I don't know
if this has ever happened to you, but,
and I'm not saying this
didn't happen once,
this didn't happen twice, this
didn't happen three times,
this happened four times over
the course of three days.
Okay.
People very obviously just
turning on their video camera
and filming.
Including-
From a distance?
No.
A guy on an elevator.
Oh that's not at a distance.
And like this.
He did this, and what I'm
doing is I'm taking my phone,
I'm placing it against-
Over your spider bite.
The spider bite.
The spider sting,
and pointing it like this.
Are you serious?
That's so obvious.
He can't look at your phone.
I looked right at it.
I didn't say anything, cause
I was like, if I'm wrong,
I'm going to sound like such an asshole.
Why did he put it up to his skin?
Why didn't he act like he was typing?
I don't know, man.
That's what the other three people did.
Four people just-
The people of Florida,
they simultaneously have no idea who I am,
but also want to track your every move
and they want to film my every action.
What is happening down there?
They need video to figure
out who you are later.
He's like, "Yeah, yeah,
I'm going to put his face
into Google so I can figure
out who this guy is."
Anyway-
You didn't just say anything
to him?
No. Jessie was like, "You
should have said something."
I was like, well, I looked-
I see you filming.
Hey dude's phone on his chest.
So if any random elevator
footage shows up of me
on the internet,
just looking at the camera awkwardly,
you know it was from Florida.
That is a weird feeling, man.
I've never had a point blank.
Four times.
I've just not spent enough
time in Florida.
You're sending your freaking child there.
Well, it's too late now.
We've already paid the
first semester tuition.
We can't get him out now.
Was there a factor it was for Lily,
which turned out to be
a total none factor,
of him concerned about
his association with you?
You being recognized?
No.
Interestingly,
when Locke first went to public school
from going from homeschool to school,
which he did in the eighth grade,
Lily did it in ninth grade.
They both did this kind
of late transition.
Locke was super sensitive about
people knowing that he was my son
and he was very much
about establishing himself
to a weird degree.
And he actually told me,
he was like, "Dad,"
okay, so, another thing
about the people of Florida,
and this is typical of any
place outside of Los Angeles,
is if you do get
recognized, the enthusiasm,
I had a couple people-
Very high.
We were in a Dick's Sporting
Goods getting some stuff,
for Locke and it was a group of teen boys,
very loudly congregated, and it was,
again, I don't really
mind, but I don't like it
when I'm with my family.
This is Locke's time, we're
moving him into college.
And then Jessie was like,
"You have to wear a hat when
you're moving him in tomorrow
and sunglasses."
Which is what you did.
And then Locke was like, "Dad, listen,
I totally don't mind.
I really don't mind.
I'm not going to be weird about it.
Listen, if somebody's a fan,
that's a benefit for me."
If we meet somebody who's a fan,
I want to know if somebody's a fan because
either I'm going to be like,
are you friends with me
cause you're a fan?
Or if somebody who works
at the university is a fan.
He's like, "Okay, listen,
I'm not going to do the thing
I did in eighth grade,
I'm actually embracing it
so you don't have to
wear a hat, whatever."
So I was like, "Okay."
I'm going to talk about the
moving in process a little bit,
and then I'll come back and talk about the
emotional aspect of this and the process.
All right, let's start with the logistics.
So interesting that you
mention packing the car
because what we had to do,
we had rented a car obviously
and we had rented the
biggest SUV that they had,
but when we got to the rental car place,
they did not have that and they said,
"We will give you a minivan and free gas."
And that was pretty much the only option
I was presented with,
so I was like, "Okay."
And I was just reminded, you
drove a minivan for many years.
It's probably more capacity than an SUV.
And I'm just telling you,
man, what an invention.
What an invention.
And it pains me that-
It's like a tall topped station wagon.
I've got too much pride to
drive one on a regular basis.
And at this point I don't need
one, I've only got one kid
at home now, I don't need one.
There was a moment in my life
when I could have used one,
but I just couldn't do it.
And Jessie, even more so than me,
she would not do the minivan,
she would not embrace
the minivan mom life.
She just was like, "I'm
not going to do it.
I'm not going to let that
grip get hold of me."
But we should have.
It was a fabulous era
of time that has passed.
Ironically, I think that Locke and Lily,
they're both candidates for a minivan.
I think that it could
draw some trouble, but
you remember Greg
had a minivan in college.
Having a minivan in college is cool.
That was an ironic,
totally functional party choice.
Low to the ground,
drives like a car,
capacity of a truck.
You can walk right into it.
It's like a walk-in shower.
You got USB-C, you got USB
whatever the other one is,
you can plug anything in.
Just very impressed with minivans.
Yeah.
You can be an adult
sitting in the middle seat
back there and you it's like you're at
a Star Trek console.
You're sitting up right.
Feel very, very-
You're ready for anything.
Advanced.
And very aerodynamic.
Now, we got a bunch of stuff,
and by the time we had packed
the car to its fullness,
it was Tetris.
In fact, Jessie took a picture,
we're going to show it right now,
cause she took a picture
when I had created the first
base layer of the Tetris
in the back of the van.
She's like, "Send that to Link."
I would loved it.
Most of the times in my
life when I'm packing things
that you got to get a bunch
of stuff, I'm with you
and you are so committed to it that I just
hand you things and you just do it.
But this was a moment where I was like
there be no could be no wasted space here,
so I'm saying things like,
"Turn that 90 degrees."
I'm actually just standing
there and Locke is doing
the stuff and I'm saying-
Oh wow, that's the life.
And he's like, "Dad, this is crazy."
And I was like, "Hey, I
guess I could have done this
all along."
I mean, every once in a
while I got to do Tetris.
No, Rhett.
Again, you learned from the best.
I've never watched you.
You've watched me.
No, no. I just hand you
the packages and move away.
You felt it.
I've never ever actually
watched you closely.
Yes you have, man.
That's how you know.
But we packed the whole,
obviously you've got the
first row and the second
row and then third row
is folded down and then
everything, ceiling to floor,
all the way back based
on stuff we had brought,
plus stuff we had bought,
was all the way full.
To the point where when you closed it,
you were catching stuff to
make sure it doesn't fall off.
Yeah. Good work.
Now
the process of moving in to
college where Locke's going,
and I don't know if this was
the case where Lily went,
but it also was the fact that
his dorm room that he is in,
he's on the 12th floor.
Good gosh.
Of a very large building.
Okay.
And what they do is,
you check in and then
you get these little tags
and then you get into a line
and you have a specified window
of time.
So it was like-
So everybody's not moving at once.
You have to be there at
5:00 PM was our window.
And you drive under this set
of awnings that they've set up,
because it's Florida and it might rain,
and you park and you open your thing
and then all these people.
Oh wow.
Not you.
A bunch of people in certain shirts,
take all your stuff and
put it in these giant bins
and then you just drive and park,
and then they take it, they go in,
they use the elevators
exclusively, so no parents or kids
are using the elevators,
get your stuff in your room
so when you get to your room
it's either they're in there
or they're bringing all the bins in there,
so you don't have to lift anything heavy.
What?
Did you have to walk up
12 flights of stairs.
And they make everybody
walk, so we had to walk up
12 flights of stairs.
Oh, seriously?
Yeah, but we didn't have anything.
We had given it to everyone.
That's the system.
Well, how many flights are there?
How much higher could you go?
There's just another couple of floors.
14 or 15 or something like that.
Oh man.
Didn't get the penthouse.
That's a long ways.
I guess that's a decent
trade for not having
to shuttle anything up.
Yeah.
Or course I'm totally dading
out about this, cause I'm like,
how long have they had
this system in place?
Did they start?
How many years have they done this system?
It's quite inefficient
system. I'm very impressed.
But this was the moment, as we
were pulling up in the line,
when I began to really feel
the difference that Jessie
and I bring to this particular event.
Now I don't know if you
remember what it was like
for us to move into college,
but as I was trying to remember
and tell Locke and Jessie and Shepherd;
I was like, "I don't think my
parents went up to NC State
with us.
No, no, no.
I'm almost positive they didn't.
It was
my papa took his truck,
we put everything in
the back of his truck.
I knew you would remember this.
Yeah, so he drove so he could
drive his truck back home.
And so he's the one who helped move us in.
And he didn't-
And there were no stairs.
And he didn't have any opinions about.
No.
The whole point of us
going into our dorm room
was to get us and our stuff into the room
and then it's up to you
guys to make it look
the way you want to, organize
your stuff, hang stuff up.
Of course generational
differences, first of all,
but also just family dynamics.
My parents were super
loving and supportive,
but they weren't involved
in those kinds of details.
But back in the day, when
Jessie was going off to college,
her mom was totally involved
in making her dorm room
look like a section of Wet Seal.
You remember that store?
Oh god.
You know what I mean?
Clothes hanging everywhere?
No.
Like faux leather pants
and big fluffy shirts?
I just mean intention,
well, that was what Jessie
was wearing at the time.
But yeah, they put up purple wallpaper
on one whole wall inside the dorm room.
Yeah, that's not allowed.
They got away with it because
their room had not been
painted along with other
rooms or something.
Point being-
Did Locke just know I'm going
to let her do her thing?
Well, in fact,
I was just looking at Jessie's
Instagram post about him
kind of going to the college,
and she was saying that
he's been super sweet.
And actually he was like,
"Yeah, I want my mom,
my mom is good at this.
If she's going to do the work
and she's going to be invested
in this."
But also Jessie gave Locke the quiz
that she gives to
prospective design clients
to find out what your style is
cause this is his style.
I didn't even know that this was happening
until I look at my wife's Instagram.
But it helps explain why
we had so much in that van.
Yeah.
And I'm sitting there-
Wonder what his roommate
thought of all this?
They thought it was great.
His roommate thought it was great.
And also-
That's what he told you.
No, and also, first of all,
this isn't something exclusive to Jessie.
You could kind of see parents
are just way more involved
in kids lives than they
were when we were coming up
about stuff like this and
their mom and dad are in there,
they're putting stuff on the wall.
So this is not just
something that's happening,
but it's on one end of the
spectrum when it comes to Jessie,
and I'm on the other end of
the spectrum, cause I'm like,
you're thinking about
the colors of things?
Just put him in the room
and hug him and say bye.
Right. Yeah.
But the way that this
translates into your minivan
is it's full of stuff,
and so as we're pulling up
to this thing, I'm thinking,
I'm looking at the other families.
There's a family in a hatchback
and the family gets out of
the hatchback and then just
opens the hatchback and that's
all the stuff this girl has.
And then I'm like, oh,
there's a family with-
She has to build a new life on our own.
There's a family with a pickup truck
and the bed of the truck,
it's an extend cab, so
the better of the truck's
not too long and the
stuff's not popping up
over the end of the thing.
But we have Tetrised an entire minivan.
And when we open the door,
things are going to fall out.
I'm beginning to feel shame.
Yeah.
And then I'm thinking,
well, how many boxes
are they going to give us?
How many of these big ass
crates are we going to fill up?
And who's going to be watching?
I know this is all irrational.
And you wish you had a disguise again.
Oh yeah.
And I'd already been recognized by a few,
as we keep sneaking through this thing,
we've got our windows rolled
down and there's families.
"Rhett!
Good mythical morning!"
and stuff like that.
"Where's your buddy?"
So we get to there and we open it up and
it was almost like the
guys with the big bins
had been prepped to
not let you feel shame.
Okay.
Because
we opened the thing and
then Jessie was like,
"My husband feels shame."
She said it, "My husband feels
shame about how much stuff
we had."
And he was like, "Oh no,
we've seen more than this."
And then he was like, "How many carts?
What's the most number of
carts that we filled up today?"
as they were filling up the fourth cart,
he said, "I think it's five or six."
And then another guy was
being honest, said four.
So I was like, okay, so
we're tied for the record.
Four of these big ass bins.
But just kind of going through that
relieved a little tension.
Getting up to the room and
then beginning the process;
she wanted to do a headboard.
A headboard that you stick to the wall.
I love the fact that none of
this is about Locke at all.
We'll get to that.
A sticky headboard.
A what?
Isn't it a bunk bed?
No, it's not.
Beds are on the ground on
each side of the thing.
And there's no option for
making them in the bunk beds
in this particular room.
It'd be helpful if there were
because it would be bigger.
Cause it's small.
Smaller than our dorm room.
What?
But I did tell Locke,
"Hey, this is the same
size the one I was in
my freshman year."
But the headboard, I'm going
to point out the headboard
because it's kind of indicative of
the difference in approach.
First of all, Locke,
he's empowered Jessie.
Didn't it to have a headboard?
No.
It's just a bed-
With a mattress.
It's a frame basically.
There is no headboard.
But then there's a wall
that it's up against that,
and this is a common thing,
you can put the headboard
up on the wall, you can mount
it on the wall above a bed.
I understand.
And this is made for
a twin bed, which is what
you get in a dorm room.
But there's a weird thing with
the way that there's a board
and then it's got these
sticky things on it,
cause you can't put any holes in the wall,
so you have to do it
with these sticky things,
but they weren't lined up right.
I spent a lot of time on this headboard,
and then
eventually had to abandon
the headboard because
it just wouldn't work.
And when I get into my
emotional processing,
I'll come back to the headboard.
But I think that,
first of all, I witnessed so many families
impatiently being short with each other
or outright yelling at each other
as we would go around
to the different stores.
Tensions are high.
We went to the Target and
everyone's buying stuff.
And we didn't even go
to the closest Target,
we went to the second closest Target,
and still, they had all descended upon it.
Oh yeah.
People just mad at each other.
Just family's falling apart
at this integral time.
And I was like, we're just
another one of these families
that's mad at each other.
We weren't really being
mean to each other,
but I was definitely
frustrated cause I was like,
I'm trying to deal with this emotionally
and trying to figure out
what is it that I'm feeling,
which is always a difficult thing for me.
And we're trying to make
his room feel this way
and it doesn't feel like a priority to me.
And this dad is yelling at his
son because the son just said
something mean to the mom.
And I just kept witnessing
these situations.
But it also made me feel
good cause I was like-
Makes it easier to part ways.
We're just another family.
We're just another family
that's dealing with this
momentous thing.
Yeah. At least you're not in Florida.
Oh, sorry.
So to talk a little bit about
the processing of this.
From Locke's perspective,
he's been simultaneously
super excited about school,
but also increasingly anxious about like,
oh, I'm not going to be at home anymore,
and I'm also not going
to be in the same city
or the same state.
Or the same time zone or coast.
That's beginning to sink in with him.
So a lot of his conversation
was around just,
and of course Locke says
exactly what he's thinking,
exactly what he's feeling,
which is a huge difference between
me at his age
and him.
So we are constantly discussing
and talking about things.
There's some anxiety around
just the transition for him.
I mean he handled it really, really well
and he's doing great and I've
talked to him a couple times
since I've gotten back
and he's really adjusting,
meeting people and
beginning to embrace the I am on my own,
but also not really.
They're not really on their own.
They can FaceTime with us at any moment.
And obviously if there's
something that they need,
it can be arranged.
It's not as on their own as
they will feel in four years.
One of the things I've
been thinking about,
first of all, there's a lot
of stuff going on right now
in life.
There's just a number of
things, I'm not going to go
into detail and nothing in
particular is standing out,
but this is a really busy time of year,
there's things that are
stressful and anxiety inducing,
and then there's this
thing that's happening
where your son is going off the college
and much like you kind of
communicated last time,
you're trying to make it into something.
Dads tend to do this
too, make it meaningful,
and you want to say the right
thing at the right time,
but you also want to feel;
and this isn't something
that I would've done 10,
15 years ago, but I want to
make sure that I'm feeling this
in the way that I should
feel it and processing it
in the way that I should process it,
which is more of a result of therapy
and also understanding
that you can have feelings
and you can process those feelings.
Which I've gotten much better at.
But I've also been anticipating
the really intense,
emotional reaction, the walking
through the neighborhood
crying situation that happened with you.
Yeah.
And what I realized, well, first of all,
that hasn't happened yet.
But what has happened is
a series of 10,
over the past couple of months,
10 moments of emotion
that will be some degree of crying.
It might just be like
welling up a little bit.
It might be weeping a little bit.
Okay.
The way I describe it is
when you've shaken up a soda,
the bottle, and you're like,
if I open this all at once
it's going to go crazy, but if I just go.
Open it a little bit at a time,
by the time I fully open
it, it'll be just like,
oh, it's just a soda.
And I think that that
might be what's happening.
Because I've had a couple
of moments of really
emotional processing.
The first was putting
together his slideshow for his
graduation thing that you came to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And looking at all these photos and
organizing them and
picking his favorite songs
and putting in.
There was an intense moment
I was sitting in bed editing
and I was crying.
So that was the beginning
of processing it.
The second thing is
I wrote him and Shepherd a song.
Right.
It was part of the process
of thinking about your
parenting changing as you deconstruct, but
I was really thinking about
Locke, especially leaving.
Here he goes. He's going off.
It's like, you've done what you can do.
He's going to be dealing with
that for the rest of his life.
Whatever you did.
And then playing him the song.
That was the last song that I played.
I played it for him and Shepherd.
You played the track,
you didn't play a guitar.
Oh, I could have never played it for him,
I would be a mess, I wouldn't
be able to make it through it.
So yes, I played the track.
Locke was driving his car,
me and him and Shepherd
went out to eat or whatever
and then we played the song
and it was
crying.
Tears were welling up in Locke as well.
I didn't really look back at Shepherd.
It was emotional for all three of us.
Sure, yeah.
But there was this
emotional moment
and then we spent some
time talking after that.
And then there's been,
tying it back into to your
story about Lily last year,
I think I actually remember
saying my application
is I want to make this
year count with Locke.
Cause Locke,
he's super independent.
He's always gone.
He's always hanging out with his friends.
This summer he's traveled
with his friends.
He's been gone.
So it's not every night
you walk in, there's Locke.
It's like, no, Locke's
probably not going to be there.
So he's sort of already kind
of established his independence
in his not being at home.
But I was like, I want to make
the most of the time we have.
And so that was my kind of goal.
And then we had those two road trips.
We had the road trip over Christmas,
we had the road trip over spring break,
which those were awesome.
And that was actually, as
we finished in Florida,
that was one of the reasons he chose
the school that he chose.
And then we've just had more
just hanging out as friends
time where it's not
this is a dad and this is a son,
and the dad is saying things to the son
to try to correct him or guide him
and the son is challenging.
That's been a lot of our relationship
cause he's a challenger.
But this past year has
been more of a friendship.
And there's been a couple of
times where we just hung out
and just talked.
And I have to hold
myself back a little bit
from going into dad
mode and advice mode or
here's a principle that
you should take with you
and just be like, let's just connect.
And so there's been more of that.
More than ever this past year.
And then, when we were in Florida,
we moved him in basically,
and then we hung out;
or no, this was the night
before we moved him in.
And me and him just went out
and just walked around town
for a while and just spent
a bunch of time talking
about everything, including
how he was feeling
and everything.
And then in addition to that,
there's just been multiple
times where I'll see something,
I'll look at his room or
whatever and there'll be
just a moment of
emotion where
tears will start
and I'll kind of let it happen.
But again, it doesn't turn into
an avalanche or a waterfall.
Yeah, it's just these
moments of I'm living
this milestone moment.
Yeah.
It's not just about
acknowledging emotions,
but acknowledging the experience.
Emotions are a part of it.
It's about fully processing things,
and they're a component of it.
But it's not like,
when am I going to break down?
Well, but I just
anticipated that happening.
Cause I acknowledge that's what I made it
out to be a lot.
I forced it.
And then now I have a
mitigated perspective on it.
Cause you keep seeing Lily.
Yeah.
She keeps coming home.
She keeps coming home. I keep seeing her.
Now that's going to be
less the case for a Locke
cause he is going to be further away.
But I think we'll be more connected
via phone than we ever
are when he's in town.
Cause it's the only way to do it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but in that moment,
in those couple of days,
yeah, it's just having
those times when it's
an acknowledgement of
you're living this
trope, you're living this
milestone moment that
you'll never have it again.
Even if he goes somewhere
else and when Shepherd
goes somewhere and same with my kids.
The first kid going off to college
and everything associated
with it is special.
But the logistics of it do
get in the way sometimes.
Oh, I've got a brave Target.
We're upset with each other.
Well, I have a very specific
thing that happened at
the moment of truth.
My adult life,
especially the past 10 years in California
and the past, what, five years in therapy,
you know the McLaughlins,
we don't make a big deal out of anything.
When people make a big deal
about something we're like
does this person got a weakness?
What is it about this person
that they're making a big deal
about this because we don't
make a big deal about anything.
Does this person have a weakness?
Yes.
I was asking Shepherd.
We all do.
Shepherd last night, I was like,
cause me and she are
just hanging out together
as we wait for Jessie to get back.
She still trying to get that headboard up?
Yeah, probably.
I hope at least she takes a picture of it.
I'm asking him how he's processing it and
he was like, "Do you remember
when Cole went off to college?"
And I was like,
"No."
But I would not be
surprised if we did not hug.
Just to be completely honest with you.
Now I would say that for a couple reasons;
number one, he was just
going to Chapel Hill,
and so he was going to be 45 minutes away.
And so it was like, oh, you're
just going to be up the road.
My family didn't make moments of things.
Jessie's family makes moments of things.
I remember the first birthday
celebration I went to
for somebody, I can't
remember, and I was like,
whoa, you guys-
Somebody was having a moment.
I'm like, you guys make
a moment of everything.
My family, we're just kind of,
we're not Jehovah's witnesses,
we don't not believe
in birthdays.
Or blood transfusions.
You're going to get your
fried chicken and your cake
and again, I don't want to miscommunicate,
it's not that there wasn't a love there,
it wasn't sentimental outwardly.
I'm not saying I know we didn't hug,
but I'm just saying I
wouldn't be surprised.
I know that there wasn't
some moment where it was like
let's hug and let's say
things to each other
in the way that Locke and Shepherd.
In fact, I started filming
them in the room as they
hugged each other and stuff
and then Locke said something
offensive to Shepherd
in order to-
Break the tension.
Because he was like, "Dad,
it was stupid that you were
filming us, I was just trying to"-
Make it unusable.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just said something mean to Shepherd,
but it was obviously in jest.
My adult life has been figuring out
that isn't who I am.
That's the way that we did things,
but A, not the person I married.
I married somebody on the
opposite end of the spectrum
in terms of making things into a moment
and expressing themselves.
It isn't that I don't have feelings,
I actually have a whole lot,
but they come out sideways
because they don't
process in a healthy way all the time.
They do more and more.
But anyway, that was an
interesting thing to hear Shepherd
talk about and ask me that question.
I was like, "Man, I don't know.
We just didn't do things in this way."
But I'm a different person now.
And so I am thinking about this moment,
and the way that it worked was-
Meaning the goodbye?
The goodbye.
The send off.
We're in his room
and this is day two.
Day one was moving all
the stuff up and beginning
to put it in, but because
we moved in at 5:00 PM
and then he had an event
he had to go to that night,
Jessie and I kind of stayed
in his room til 9:00, 9:30
and then we left and then we were like,
we're going to come back
tomorrow, there's a few things
that we need to get and then
I'll just leave from here
to go to the airport.
And so we're in his room,
and it took us a while to
get a couple of things,
so we had one hour in his room
and I had to get the damn headboard up!
Still dealing with the damn headboard!
This is headboard take two.
Have a new idea for what I'm going to do
and it may involve violating school policy
and putting a nail in the wall.
It didn't cause it didn't work.
But at some point I'm looking
in the clock and I'm like,
okay, I have 12 minutes cause
I've timed this of course,
to be able to get to the airport on time,
I have 12 minutes left in
the room based on the time
it will take to get back to the car.
Still have not figured the headboard out.
So I was like, I can't do this headboard.
I think it's a bad idea.
I'm going to take it down
and y'all can figure it out tomorrow
because Jessie was going to be back.
The headboard had been
a point of contention,
or it was representative of
multiple points of contention
about the way that Jessie
and I were relating
in this situation.
And also there's a lot
of emotion and I'm trying
to deal with this.
What am I thinking? What am I
feeling about Locke leaving?
And I set the headboard
down and then I'm like,
okay, I got to go.
I mean, I got to go, meaning
I got to go and I want us
to be able to say goodbye.
Yeah.
And so at that moment
Locke's like, "Oh man.
This is it."
This is it.
So he does this thing
with Shepherd and then
me and him hug and I say,
I don't know what I said,
we said some things and I'm tearing up.
Jessie, in that moment,
Jessie is like, "Okay, I'm
going to get this trash,"
or she says something
logistical in that moment.
Cause she's staying.
Because she's staying.
And I was like, "What are you doing?"
I was like,
"I'm leaving!"
I'm like, me and Shepherd
are not coming back.
Didn't you hear Locke say, "This is it?"
And so, I'm not trying to
throw Jessie under the bus,
or the headboard or anything.
But she was coming back
and it had not quite,
and she's processing this on her own,
it had not hit her.
Cause she's trying to get all
this stuff done in his room
and that hit her in the moment.
Oh yeah, this is their moment,
this is the last moment
that they have together.
Not ever.
But as she's leaving.
And so we are kind of at each other,
but that immediately
impacted the nature of the process.
And then of course she
was like, "I'm sorry.
I'm coming back.
I'm just thinking about
the fact that we're going
downstairs and we've got all
this stuff we need to take."
I was like, "Trust me, I'm
the one that would usually
do exactly what you did.
I'm just surprised that you did it."
But Locke and I, he went
out into the hall with us
and I hugged him three or four times.
There was not one moment.
It was just like, I guess
I'll just hug you again.
It sort of perfectly encapsulated just how
you can't script this
thing out in a way that
make it perfect and make it
exactly the memorable thing
where you're going to say
exactly the right thing
at the right time.
He's going to remember this forever.
And he is probably going to
remember that in this moment
I snapped at Jessie because
she was trying to take
some trash down the stairs.
But in a sense it's like-
No, he won't remember anything.
That's my parents.
Maybe.
I don't think he'll remember that.
And then of course I
ended up talking to him
three or four more times before-
Did you turn around and
take a picture of him
walking back in?
That was the thing I
was going to ask about.
No.
I took a picture of all
four of us right before
he walked out.
Okay.
Took a selfie of all four of us.
That's good. That counts.
And Locke has a look on his face.
Well, I'll show that picture.
But Locke has a look on his face like
this is it.
That's the look on his face.
He was feeling it for sure.
We ended up talking three or
four times before I even got
on the plane because I'm
trying to logistically
figure things out.
But the thing I was thinking about,
have been thinking about,
is just the
aspect of,
oh man,
I've done all I can do.
I've kind of been at
this place for a while.
I've just kind of observed
the way children are
and known that
it's much more about what
you do than what you say.
They're taking a lot more
cues from the way you act
and the things you do than
the things you tell them.
They're usually just kind of
zoning out when you tell them things.
But that doesn't stop
you from wanting to say
exactly the right thing.
If there are three pieces of wisdom
that he could take with him
into this freshman year,
what would they be?
I want to make sure
that I say those things.
It doesn't stop you from doing that.
But I think there's just this sense of
all right,
yes,
I still am the one
that's going to be putting money into his
prepaid credit card thing or whatever.
There's still a connection.
There's still a big connection.
I'm still the one paying for this thing.
And he is a phone call away-
And he's communicative.
That's the other thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
I think that
he'll talk to people on the phone.
He's not averse to FaceTime
and stuff like that.
Didn't you tell me he'll talk to people?
Locke calls my dad,
his father-in-law.
His father-in-law?
I mean my father-in-law, Jessie's dad,
my brother,
Jessie's brother-in-law.
He's good with a phone.
He's just like, I'm going
to call an older person
and just talk to them.
And he's done that for years.
So yeah, he instigates a lot of things.
That bodes well.
I'm not worried about it.
He makes friends
really easily.
You're not going to
bother him by calling him.
No.
That'll make a huge
difference than texting.
There's still very much a connection.
Having already built those type of habits.
From my experience, that goes a long way.
If I get a text from Lily about nothing,
it's just like, oh, that feels great.
It's not just me initiating everything.
One specific
thing that felt;
you kind of feel the powerlessness,
and I think this is
due mostly
just to the fact that
your kid's going to be
out of your supervision
and off in college,
but also,
the person that Locke is,
his room was always a mess back at home.
You have to tell him to clean stuff.
He's like me.
And Jessie's the same way.
Our house is remarkably
organized for what the nature of
our personalities is.
Cause that's not the tendency.
Things like,
"Locke I'm telling you
this thing about where
I'm putting this,"
and kind of looking in your
eyes and seeing that this is
not sinking in.
You're going to have a
room that you're sharing
with this other guy,
and you got to keep it clean and
I'm giving you your passport.
You are going to be
responsible for your passport.
You know what I'm saying?
The sense of trepidation
that I hand this document
off to him and where is
this going to end up?
No one will know.
Including him, definitely.
I know Lily's different.
Lily's more buttoned up
than Locke when it comes to those things,
so you probably didn't have this
is she going to be able
to manage the space
that she's living in?
No, she's probably going to
manage it for other people too.
But Locke-
All five of them
as a matter of fact in her room.
Locke is different than this.
But then there's this sense of
I didn't know I about any of this stuff.
I was not organized at all.
You figure it out.
You probably make mistakes.
Well, you had me, Rhett.
You had me, man.
And I also lost my passport at one point.
I don't recall caring too much.
I was excited to decorate the room
with the occasional poster.
We didn't have enough
stuff to make a mess.
You know what I'm saying?
I didn't have enough things
to really make a mess in.
I was definitely one that initiated,
all right, we're spending
the next three hours
cleaning this place.
Yeah.
And also, I don't remember
ever changing my sheets.
Yeah, that's a scary thought.
Did you change your sheets?
Well, you just feel like it's not needed.
Yeah. I wasn't a clean freaking that way.
But Jessie was like, "Okay,
I'm giving you two sets
of sheets.
One that will be on the bed"-
I brought my laundry home.
I must have brought my sheets home.
"The other one while
you're washing your sheets,
which you should do at
least once a month,"
is what she said.
Yeah.
Preferably every two weeks.
And then I'm thinking, he's
not going to do that at all.
He's not going to do that.
He's not going to wash his sheets.
And it'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
Some sort of colony will grow in there.
He'll probably get some
sort of good probiotics
that go straight through his feet skin.
I don't know how it works.
But there is that sense of
helplessness of
ah, he's just-
Can't do it for him.
He's just going to figure it out.
I can't hold this for him anymore.
And you know what? He'll be just fine.
Well, I hope so.
I think he will.
The communication part is so huge.
He's not dropping off the edge of
a planet and trying to escape you.
He was confident enough to
go clear across the country.
You know what, to his own credit
and to you and Jessie's credit too.
He was ready to make that leap.
You know he's ready.
That's the big thing for me is
just knowing that he's going
to tell you what's happening.
He's very upfront
and he's also communicative.
That's so much more important
than everything else.
I'm speaking from experience here.
Everything that I made a huge
deal about, I'm glad I did,
but people told me,
I'd gotten the advice,
I spent the whole next day
after my first daughter left
for college crying.
And then
that was kind of it,
I was kind of over it.
I was like, well, okay,
that's helpful to hear.
It was kind of true even
though I pushed it so hard.
I want to fully experience this.
I think about with Lincoln,
he just yesterday just
started his senior year
of high school, so we'll be
having this conversation.
But the conversation that we
have about Lincoln will be
totally different than the
conversation that I had
about Lily.
And also, different than
the conversation you had
about Locke.
That middle child syndrome.
Again, I feel for him.
You wouldn't even know
If he's in college.
I might not even be there.
Is he here?
I'll definitely be there.
Yeah,
it's just a different thing.
But you've gone through it.
You've checked this box.
And that, for you, just
talk about you for a second,
it's a privilege that
you got to experience it
under these circumstances.
That you have this
intact
and rewarding relationship with Locke that
it set the
groundwork for this
experience for you as a dad.
That you'll never have again,
you won't have it with Shepherd.
That is the most important thing.
We talked about this before.
That the goal, especially as
you get into the teenage years,
and kids tend to get cynical,
they get harder to communicate with,
they get more private
and they may even get mean.
I think that happens
with a lot of teen kids,
they just kind of get
mean to their parents.
Let me just say, we've
been through those phases.
It's not like it's been
all smooth sailing.
He is a teenager, he's
been through these phases
of a teenager.
Oh, he's really connecting
with this parent
and not liking this parent
and going back and forth.
You cleared a number of hurdles
at such a point that
by the time you're sending
him off to college,
it's not part of it.
Well, ultimately what I'm saying though is
at some point along the way,
we received very good
advice that we have been
preaching to one another, me and Jessie,
of maintain the relationship.
Above all else.
The first priority needs to be
maintaining the relationship.
Not getting him to think a certain way.
Not getting him to do a certain thing.
I've tried those things.
Obviously there's principles
and boundaries within which
you're accomplishing that
that's not coddling, spoiling
and just giving in to everything.
Oh, of course.
There's a difference between
disagreeing and destroying a relationship.
Sometimes it gets precarious
and I know you're not
saying that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just saying that-
You don't worship him.
No, of course not.
There are these
moments in which
I can choose to say
something or do something
or implement something
that will be
long term damaging to the relationship.
And this is not some
easy thing to navigate,
cause you're right, this
doesn't mean you don't
have standards, you
don't have expectations,
you don't have house rules or whatever
and you don't give advice.
We do all that stuff.
But not at the expense
of the relationship.
And I'm not 100% sure that
we would've gotten there.
This was something that our
therapist started telling us
and I'm sure we would've
gotten it or realized it
in a different way, but
when we began to have some
difficulties as Locke kind of
got into his teenage years,
and that was the thing
that was the mantra,
it was like, maintain the relationship.
I'm so thankful that that
became the mantra because
this past year has been the
best stage in our relationship.
Which is exactly what
you want right before
you send him off.
Not counting the
headboard thing, but yeah.
Yeah.
And one of the things that
he has said that he said
more and more over the past year,
and it has increased in frequency is
he would say things like
"I'm going to miss you guys."
The things that you want
to hear as a parent.
He's like, "You know,
we haven't always agreed on everything,
and I haven't always
agreed with the things
that you've done, but
I know the motivation
has always been love."
Okay.
Yeah. Take and store that one.
I'm like, that is what you
want to hear as a parent.
I think I've always thought
maybe when he's in his
30s and he's got kids,
he'll come back and he'll say,
"The motivation was always love."
But to hear it now was like,
wow.
Yeah.
Don't screw this up, Locke.
Remember who you are.
You don't want your dad to
have to come on this podcast
and say something about you.
You want me to do it for you?
Say what?
All the things that I'm saying right now.
It's like, don't forget
what you're in college for.
It's to study.
It is to become
knowledgeable
about stuff.
You better make good grades.
How else am I supposed to know?
I've got to look at your grades.
I have to know.
Stuff like that?
Well, he does have an incentive.
Be a good boy.
For making good grades.
He actually asked that.
He was like, if I make
straight A's, will you,
and then he proposed
a prize.
A prize?
Oh.
And I said-
Tell him
it's a solidified future.
I was like, "I'm not above this.
Yes, I will incentivize
you to make straight A's."
Straight A's?
I was like, you should
have said straight A's
and one B maybe.
I think that's a little unrealistic.
Okay.
So yeah. Locke's off.
He's off.
He's off. He's gone.
I have one got one.
Course his mama's still there with him.
She needs to get back.
She's probably on a plane right now.
Okay.
Or about to be.
All right.
Wonder how that went?
What do you mean?
Jessie getting on a plane?
Yeah.
I'm sure she's fine.
No. Them saying goodbye.
You should have called them at the moment
that she was telling him goodbye-
Make sure you get that trash.
Talk about the trash.
Oh, it's my turn to have a rec.
I'm trying to come up with
a rec that's related to
just a very practical
recommendation from fatherhood.
You haven't thought about this until now?
Well, I always like to keep it themed.
Keep it themed, man.
But I'm not going to do that.
You know I love hiphop documentaries.
Only if you're really into
the history of hiphop
can I advise you to
take my recommendation.
But if you are,
I think you'll love
"Dilla Time."
J Dilla.
If you start to get into
the world of hiphop history,
then it's really cool
to know about J Dilla.
I'm just going to be honest.
Okay.
Here's a whole book about his life.
He's a producer that
he was mentored by Q-Tip and
he started producing tracks
for them in their later albums
that aren't quite as notable.
I don't want to go into
all the details, but
J Dilla passed away
and he was this super producer of hiphop
that was,
in Dan Charnas, the author's perspective
and argument, he presents
that he created this whole
new type of time.
Like musical time,
which he calls Dilla Time.
Like a beat signature?
A beat signature that is
a combination of straight
and swung time by
moving tracks independently
from each other
to create a groove.
So on one hand, it's like
a lot of music theory,
and then on the other hand, it's
a biography of his life and
it kind goes back and forth.
And there's a lot of hiphop
history that's kind of
intermingled in both of those two
tracks that he takes.
So if you're like me,
you're really into that.
You'll love "Dilla Time."
Even though I have not
been a fan of his music,
I was unknowingly a fan
of many of his tracks
from back in the day.
It's a good education if you're into it.
Proceed with caution.
Don't blame me if it's not for you.
This feels like a mild rec.
Mild rec.
It's a strong rec if
that's what you're into.
"Dilla Time." Listen to it on Audible.
Okay.
M'kay?
M'kay.
Talk at you next week.
Hey Rhett and Link, this
is Audrey from Illinois,
I listen to your guys'
podcast every single day
at the garden that I work at
and when I was a teenager,
I did just sit in my bed
and watch your biscuits
for an hour straight.
Just watch you guys.
And the longest I've
stayed up is 38 hours.
So love you guys. Bye.
What's up, Rhett and Link, my name's Will
and I'm an environmental
engineering student from Ontario.
I just listened to you
talk about composting
and I wanted to pass on
some interesting facts.
So first of all, there are
automated systems for removing
plastics and other foreign
objects from compost.
So no one needs to dig
in with their hands.
Number two, organic waste
accounts are about 40%
of landfill waste.
So there are major land use savings
from composting.
Also, digesters and bio
reactors capture methane
and burn it for electricity
or convert it to
renewable natural gas.
The nutrient rich compost
produced can also be sold
and the reactor conditions
are super optimized,
so even bones are
composted within 60 days.
Thanks for talking about
this. Love you guys.
Hey, Rhett and Link, I just listened
to the most recent podcast
episode about sleeping
and also the compost
bucket, and I just wanted
to let you know that I
was born in the year 2000
and I still throw my
banana peels out the window
on the side of the highway.
Whether that's good or
bad, that's what happens.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist
on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.